Hey what is happening what up it's your
boy PewDiePie
big announcement big announcement big
announcement let's get some excitement
everyone got a big announcement I'm
going family-friendly now
so no more swearing no more sexual jokes
and definitely not any Hitler jokes okay
nothing
none of that ah I wish I was joking I'm
not
it seems that YouTube has made some
changes about a third of my videos got
demonetised I'm gonna have to you know
family friendly from now on so I don't
go homeless okay I love money too much I
love money too much okay
no more swearing family friendly Felix
as I like to call myself Felix the
family Felix the family that's right
from now on we're not calling it broach
we're calling it family what's that did
I make less money yesterday than I did
in 2013 Rucka Rucka Ali did a really
good song I can't show it because this
video will get demonetized but Lincoln's
in the description I think you'll enjoy
it it's a legit good song would love to
show it but I can public service
announcements okay they're made to
protect families public service
announcements they're made to make
families happy and that's what we do on
family friendly Felix Channel my family
how you doing my family handshake
handshakes as we do in there please to
me we don't do brofist anymore we're
doing handshakes so we're gonna go
through some public service
announcements for family friendliness to
protect the families hopefully we can
learn something and become more family
friendly this one is from America it's
called don't put it in family friendly
it's family friendly don't it's
seriously bad okay let's say let's see
what it says why do you think your mommy
or daddy are always telling you don't
put that in your mouth cuz you're a
[ __ ] damn it
God no family friendly Felix okay here
we go I know why do you look like you're
about to murder me both of you
if I saw you two in an alleyway I would
I would scream I would scream and I
would run for my life
tell a little story about why you
shouldn't put things into your mouth
you don't know what they are the
lip-syncing is impeccable about why you
shouldn't put things into your mouth and
why you should never take anything
a stranger tries to give you why not
never listen to anyone that doesn't
blink rule number one foreign family
friendly Felix tips if I don't blink if
they don't blink
you're gonna have a problem alright if
you ever meet anyone that talks to you
like this you may want to run run and
hide call ah it's somebody else's
medicine some bad food or some poison
you could get very sick kids wanna get
sick okay when I was a kid I wanted to
get sick alright if my sister was was
sick I would go to her room play video
games in there I'm sick I get sick from
her and then I get to stay home in
school from school and play video game
you can't say I don't want to get sick
and think kids will understand okay I
love you can he pick a card no oh my god
oh my god this is worse than I thought
okay well she's clearly not paying
attention but but you can help me sing a
song about eating things that don't
belong inside you okay I'm really hungry
anyways oh wait maybe I love it okay
everybody it's so cringy it's just so
cringy if you see something that you
want to eat before you do anything
remember this song
[Music]
oh my god there's more of them
hey what am i doing I don't even know
like beats then don't put it in your
mouth bye-bye everyone remember you
telling me not to eat healthy stuff now
you're not supposed to eat beet beet
roots they're good for you they're good
for what what is that fig what is that
boys and girls never take anything from
a stranger and don't put things in your
mouth when you don't know what they are
or listen to crack cocaine addict Lyons
I always ask someone you love before you
put anything in your mouth hey Satan
should I what my god half of people who
try cigarettes in college still smoke
four years later guys hey camera mistake
you're a smoker no I never even bought
my own pack
it's a trap why would you do that why
would you do that why never even bought
my own pack
dude I I gotta say I mean those are some
dick sucking lips like Jesus Christ I
can't make that joke sorry those are
some love making lips those are some
love making lips I got Haley it's a trap
highly smoked on Saturdays so doesn't
even count
oh no why did you say yesterday no
you're better than that I'm not a smoker
smoker I'm gonna do yoga tomorrow
I didn't it doesn't it doesn't stop it
keeps guys keeps going the memes or this
is Cringer than my content I and that's
a first
it tastes of tropical compacts
so can be bad for me
unicorn Ryan no no now I just feel like
smoking okay I don't even smoke and I
just definitely okay let's move on
before I said everyone start smoking
okay it's the only way to do it how God
is one of our trains is so happy now pin
back your ears and listen because I'm
gonna tell you a story okay it's all
about the railways did you know mint day
over 18,000 trains use our railway
system amazing isn't it
no I'm I'm amazed I do a great deal of
rushing around the country from place to
place and I can't think of a nicer more
comfortable way of doing that than in a
really good train yeah the hell is that
what the hell is that what is that look
this guy is in love with trains I think
my story really is about something else
I knew it your love for trains or rather
someone else a lad called Robby oh my
god a lad called Robby it legit looks
like me when I was kid
equally stupid as well Robbie I already
hate you tonight at this point I just
want Robbie to get hit by a train to be
honest what's happening he won't be
wearing those sad
Robbie still keeps his boots nobody
knows why not even Robbie after all
they'll never be any Eustace Oh Robbie
bless em chances are he'll spend the
rest of his life in his wheelchair oh my
god oh my god
okay well I mean it's a good message I
understand it's a problem there's so
many railroads and people aren't careful
and trains come a lot quicker than you
think and you don't really hear them as
well so I understand the danger but this
like was this the best way to tell
[Music]
I just love that screaming so much it's
the best it's the best scream I ever
heard then had a really good train oh my
god he's gonna get electrified
[Music]
good
he's gonna get electrified dude don't go
up there you got it no why is this funny
it's not fun there's nothing funny about
it but it's also hilarious well you
shouldn't have told him to get the fresh
speak family-friendly Felix well I hope
you enjoyed it's been my pleasure for
you to all bring as always
family-friendly content here on
family-friendly Felix Channel remember
to do would leave a like and